[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour une nouvelle
semaine d'information sur tv 78 tout de
suite les titres de ce lundi 17 février
plus de 600 bénévoles pour une
reconstitution historique au mois de
juin le château de rambouillet remonte
le temps direction en 1959 le général de
gaulle reçoit le président américain
dwight eisenhower un spectacle immersif
porté par polaris production elle la
page dédiée aux élections municipales à
voisins le bretonneux une troisième
liste s'est déclarée pour le scrutin
avec vos voisins avancé menée par
béatrice pierrât une première campagne
pour la tête de liste
et puis un mot de sport pas de trêve
pour ces vacances les matchs ne s'arrête
pas notamment au rugby retour sur les
principaux résultats de ce week end
avant de développer ces titres le siège
de mcdonald's france service à
guyancourt connaît une vague de
licenciements depuis mars 2010 8 11
salariés ont été licenciés au sein du
département ressources humaines des
licenciements que des salariés et des ex
salariés présente comme abusif
parmi les motifs annoncé manque de
loyauté et comportement inapproprié
contacté par nos confrères du parisien
la direction a réfuté tout problème au
siège juillan courtois il y a deux
semaines les systèmes d'information de
bouygues construction était attaqué le
30 janvier le site installé à guyancourt
a été victime d'une cyber-attaque à
travers un rand somewhere c'est un
logiciel malveillant qui permet de
prendre en otage des données
informatiques
les pirates demandé une rançon de 10
millions d'euros aujourd'hui les système
fonctionnerait que partiellement signe
que la cyber sécurité devient un enjeu
de plus en plus important écoutez à ce
propos françois feugeas expert en cyber
sécurité et fondateur d'auxi box
start-up implantée à guyancourt les
propos sont recueillis par nicolas
landry
ça nous apprend que personne n'est à
l'abri c'est à dire que si effectivement
une attaque est capable de pénétrer les
défenses de bouygues construction
elle est capable de pénétrer les
défenses de la cazine importe quasiment
n'importe quelle entreprise en france et
donc toutes les entreprises en france on
dirait dans leur responsabilité de
prendre des mesures pour être capable de
répondre à ce type de menace et d'être
capable justement de garantir leur
capacité à redémarrer rapidement
l'activité après une attaque de ce type
aucune défense n'est parfaite il faut au
moins investir dans la capacité à
redémarrer pour pouvoir assurer la
pérennité de l'entreprise
c'est une installation attendu par les
inimités depuis de nombreuses années un
mur antibruit va être installé au bord
de la 12 de longueur 2 460 mètres et
d'une hauteur de 3 mètres le mur
protégera des nuisances sonores les
habitants du quartier du pas du lac le
chantier devrait durer huit mois
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines investi 1,5 million d'euros
[Musique]
dans l'actualité du jour les vacances
continuent pour les scolaires yvelinois
les sites touristiques et culturels du
département multiplie les activités à
rambouillet la bergerie nationale
propose aux familles de mener l enquête
aurélie rose a rencontré c'est sherlock
holmes en herbe alerte à la bergerie
nationale à rambouillet un peu avant les
vacances un voleur a subtilisé un
dossier confidentiel et projette de
construire une ferme usine
l'établissement a donc mis en place une
enquête grandeur nature et demande de
l'aide aux visiteurs et plus
particulièrement aux enfants qu'il
fallait résoudre le voleur qui avait
volé les animaux ils la voulaient au
cheval
en fait il est regardé j'ai envoyé à
quelque chose et du coup on a résolu
enquête et du coup même il du coup nos
vies si ces craintes des traces de pieds
des indices ont été disséminés dans
plusieurs bâtiments et dans un
labyrinthe végétal
une animation qui permettent également
de découvrir l'environnement et les
pratiques agricoles de la bergerie
nationale
donc le but de faire réfléchir aux
césars et les enfants sur cette enquête
c'est que voilà l'idée qu'il découvre ce
qui est un peu l'agroécologie en quoi il
ya le bien
animal sur la bergerie nationale une
enquête à résoudre en famille afin de
récompenser le visiteur d'avoir mis la
main sur le coupable la bergerie offre
une entrée gratuite
très bien très bien très bien ça ça aide
tout le monde enfin de les enfants
réfléchissent
c'est pas très très compliqué donc c'est
assez adaptés pour tous les âges et
c'est pas mal comme activité est aussi
proche s'il vient et on passe un bon
après midi
l'enquète à la ferme a lieu tous les
jours de 14 heures à 16 heures jusqu'au
23 février
une animation complété par l'accès à la
traite des vaches ou encore les soins
aux animaux et on reste à rambouillet
pour parler d'un projet une
reconstitution historique qui aura lieu
au sein du château en juin prochain
durant un mois le public remontera le
temps pour découvrir une rencontre
politique et historique entre charles de
gaulle et dwight eisenhower aux manettes
de cette réalisation pour la res
production et son metteur en scène est
avec nous en plateau bonjour bonjour
alors charles mollet le principe de ce
rendez vous c'est qu'il ya plus de 600
bénévoles qui ont été recrutés ces
dernières semaines le chiffre est
atteint les 600 bénévoles
oui aujourd'hui à 600 volontaires
bénévoles qui s'engagent à nos côtés et
aux côtés du centre des monuments
nationaux pour faire revivre le château
de rambouillet dans cette journée un peu
particulière de septembre 1959 où le
général de gaulle et le général
eisenhower qui à l'époque étaient tous
deux présidents de leurs états
respectifs se se rencontre pour parler
de l'avenir du monde
on va parler de cette histoire un tout
petit peu plus tard mais on va on va
continuer sur les bénévoles ils viennent
d'où des yvelines principalement de
beaucoup de personnes
en fait pousse la porte d'un château qui
est un château voisin pour eux le
château de rambouillet c'est un côté de
chez eux c'est leur château et donc il
ya beaucoup de rambolitains beaucoup de
personnes des yvelines d'un peu plus
loin de versailles qui viennent faire
vivre ce monument mais également des
personnes qui viennent des
hauts-de-seine des personnes qui
viennent aussi de l'eure et loire
notamment du secteur de maintenon où on
a eu la chance ces dernières années de
créer un spectacle fabuleux noël donc
les gens qui connaissent cette aventure
humaine parce que c'est avant tout une
aventure humaine ou envie de continuer
le spectacle de noël à main qu'on se
trouve en décembre manifestement et donc
du coup ces personnes viennent continuer
l'aventuré
les gens viennent aussi de plus loin
encore ils viennent certains viennent de
châteaudun où on crée un spectacle au
mois de mai la grande épopée et alors là
les gens font des tas de kilomètres pour
changer de lieu de château et d'époque à
châteaudun la grande épopée ça parle de
jeanne d'arc et il se retrouve plongé en
1959 pour parler du général de gaulle
oui parce que là on est un peu plus
proche pour 959 pourquoi cet événement
là qu'est ce qui se passe en septembre
1959 en septembre 59
la france le général de gaulle vient de
revenir au pouvoir c'est la naissance de
la vème république quelques dans les
mois qui précèdent
on est empêtré dans la situation de la
guerre en algérie on est en train de
développer notre programme atomique on
espère avoir la bombe
les russes ont envoyé ce pique nique
dans l'espace ils viennent ou quelques
jours plus tard ils vont être les
premiers à écraser un engin spatial sur
la surface de la lune
on est en plein coeur de la guerre
froide dans l'univers et dans le monde
des services secrets on est à un moment
où les relations entre les états unis et
la france sont distendus et on a deux
personnages qui sont en fait des anciens
camarades de guerre puisqu'un faisait
noir était le généralissime de la
libération et le général de gaulle
évidemment vont se retrouver et vont
renouer une certaine une certaine amitié
dans un cadre diplomatique très
particulier puisque le général de gaulle
est là pour appuyer la grandeur le rend
la liberté l'indépendance de la france
dans un monde divisé en deux blocs et
cette rencontre elle préfigure ce qui va
se passer à berlin quelques années plus
tard avec le mur qui sera monté elle
préfigure ce qui va se passer à cuba
avec la crise des missiles
donc elle est passionnante parce que on
va entraîner véritablement on va
immerger le public dans les coulisses
d'une rencontre comme celle-ci et on va
découvrir le travail des services secret
des cabinets d attaché d'ambassade tout
le travail de l'ombre le travail du sdec
des services de renseignements c'est
comme comment vous savez ce qui s'est
passé en un des documents la baie de
numéros québec
tout à fait on a des documents alors on
a les documents que les téléspectateurs
ont pu voir tout à l'heure les images
d'archivés et puis il y a les documents
des chiffres qui portent cette mention
secret défense qui est notre notre plus
haut niveau de secrets d'état
parce que ces documents en fait relate
les discussions qu'il y a eu dans une
très grande intimité dans un très grand
secret sur tous les sujets que je viens
d'évoquer
et ces documents sont consultables
maintenant aux archives nationales
puisqu'ils sont ils sont libérés c'est
dire qu il valoir ok d'improvisation en
ceux qui seront les figurants si toutes
les personnes des acteurs et les
figurants vont jouer ils vont d'autant
plus alors il ya peu d'improvisation
parce qu'on est là pour raconter une
histoire mais est une histoire qui s'est
effectivement passé donc qui est très
précise dans son écriture mais on est
surtout là pour faire vivre au public
une expérience complètement folle faut
imaginer que les visiteurs vont arriver
au château ils pensent rentrer aller
voir un spectacle
pas du tout ils vont être par petit
groupe de 32 personnes c'est la raison
pour laquelle il faut absolument
réserver ses places en un mot comment
ces rénovations réservations en amont à
partir du mois d'avril sur le site
secret -d france.fr donc le même s'il
rendre dès maintenant pour s'informer
sur le spectacle on réserve par groupe
de 32 personnes le spectacle et en
continu il ya des départs toutes les 10
minutes donc on a réservé l'horaire de
14h30 on arrive au château
et là vous êtes à 400 mètres du château
et ont quatre par quatre on va vous
faire rentrer dans des véhicules
d'époque donc le livre du bien se la
jouer oui le public et acteurs c'est ce
que j'allais vous raconter on est dans
une immersion complète et c'est pour ça
que les comédiens qui se prépare en ce
moment à faire vivre ce spectacle au
public
alors va on va effectivement le le les
comédiens ont fait vont répéter à partir
du mois de mars toutes les semaines pour
accueillir le public dans cette
immersion dont l'objectif c'est quand
les gens arrivent
il embarque dans une voiture ils
remontent l'allée du château où le
véhicule s'immobilise dans la cour on a
un tapis rouge on a des journalistes qui
vont fondre sur le public qui vont lui
poser des questions il va être happé par
un acteur qui va l'emmener dans une
chambre 80% du parcours où se trouvent
dans des espaces normalement fermés au
public qui était classé justement secret
défense est inaccessible jusqu'à il ya
très peu de temps et les acteurs que
public va rencontrer passer des gens
comme comme comme vous et moi comme les
gens qui nous regardent en ce moment ils
sont pas acteurs au départ c'est pour ça
qu'ils doivent se préparer à partir du
1er mars tous les soirs au château il ya
une deuxième vie après les visites
après les visites et une petite porte
qui s'ouvre sur le côté et bien c'est
600 personnes qui viennent répéter
toutes les semaines pour les acteurs que
vous allez voir jouer à quelques mètres
de vous dans les espaces du château qui
vont jouer des chefs d'état des
diplomates des espions et puis tous les
mois pour les figurants et puis à les
grands moments de répétition générale
dans les trois mois qui précède le
spectacle donc les trois mois sont une
intense c'est un moment où où tout le
monde se retrouve
voilà revêtent pour pour apprendre et
partager ensemble parce qu'il ya toutes
les générations qui se mène dans un
projet un peu fou dont on espère être à
la hauteur pour le mener à bien pour les
20000 spectateurs attendus vous presque
et tout ça on découvrira le 5 juin
prochain château de renvoi directement
née à temps plein d'argent mais on ne
manquera pas d'avoir parlé sur notre
antenne merci des suisses un volet c'est
secret défense c'est le nom de la
reconstitution verra ça le 5 juin et ses
moments de notre vie a vu le résultat
sport et nous rejoint actuellement en
plateau mickaël millero le journaliste
aux sportifs de tv 78 bonsoir une quête
pour son maillot ni alors du rugby pour
commencer avec du championnat de
fédérale 2 avis de tempête sur plaisir
ce dimanche 16 février l'équipe locale
en difficulté en fédérale 2 recevait
sous les bourrasques de vent un autre
prétendant la descente gennevillois
après avoir concédé l'ouverture du score
les plaisirs réagissent et réussissent à
remporter la victoire sur le score de 18
à 12
réaction mon sentiment c'est que c'était
le plus beau match de la saison après
les conditions c'est sûr faisait que ça
rendait les choses un peu plus compliqué
beaucoup de vent mais bon ce n'est quand
même bien sorti
et ça donne une grosse bouffée d'oxygène
pour la suite
saison donc ça fait du bien quoi une
bouffée d'oxygène qui se traduit au
classement plaisir à dernier il ya
quelques semaines remonte à la 9e place
avec deux points d'avancé sur son
adversaire du jour
c'est la première fois de l'année qu'on
enchaîne de bons résultats 2 victoires
donc voilà j'espère que la dynamique va
pas s'arrêter à ces deux matches et puis
qu'on va pouvoir continuer à engranger
des points et on a un peu de confiance
quoi maintenant
j'ai un groupe qui est ambitieux j'ai
des joueurs qui sont ambitieux donc on
ira jusqu où on pourra aller avec grand
plaisir
pour continuer sa série de victoires
plaisir se déplacera sur le terrain de
beauvais ce dimanche 23 février le
deuxième de la poule
il y avait également du handball ce
week-end en nationale 2 féminine
montigny-le-bretonneux s'est inclinée ce
week-end à l'extérieur chez saint
grégoire rennes métropole score final 24
à 22 malgré les neuf buts de kristen
d'elgato des gr k malgré cette défaite
montigny le bretonneux reste tout de
même troisième du classement prochain
match le 29 février à domicile contre
dreux merci michael on vous retrouve
dans quelques instants pour votre
émission le 7-8 sport on continue ce
journal avec une page consacrée aux
élections municipales aux
clayes-sous-bois une table ronde était
organisée ce week-end pour parler
transition écologique avec l'équipe de
les clés avec vous 2020 la liste sans
étiquette est conduite par philippe
guillen mathilde de dominer et aurélie
rose philippe guiguen première adjoint
au maire et tête de liste les clés avec
vous 2020 a présenté 14 engagements sur
la transition écologique proposer une
alimentation biologique dans la
restauration collective protéger la
ressource en eau ou encore donner la
priorité aux mobilités actives sont les
quelques sujets abordés lors de cette
table ronde
nous avons décidé de signer le pacte de
transition écologique pour 14 de nos des
préoccupations principales
nous allons donner à l'assemblée qui
sera là des exemples par rapport à ce
pacte de transition écologique pour
démontrer que même au niveau d'une
commune nous pouvons agir dans le cadre
cette transformation écologique
trente-cinq personnes ont rejoint
l'adjoint au maire qui a finalisé sa
liste son programme mené principalement
sur les notions environnementales sera
présenté dans les jours à venir
sophie stucki coulisses terre a rejoint
la campagne de philippe dit guen pour
son engagement écologique on est
nombreux aussi
avoir conscience des enjeux du
réchauffement climatique
on est nombreux aussi avoir envie de ré
enchanter un peu l'écologie de dire ben
voilà 25% de canton de baisses
d'émissions des gaz à effet de serre
quand on est individuelle mais en terme
collectif on peut faire aussi beaucoup
mieux donc on avait envie de s'engager
collectivement donc bas avec la jeunesse
de la liste mais aussi justement des
plus anciens la prochaine réunion
publique de philippe guiguen se tiendra
le 6 mars prochain
la maire sortante véronique côté millard
ne se représentant pas la liste les clés
avec vous 2020 et pour l'instant face à
trois autres listes à voisins le
bretonneux le premier tour devrait voir
s'affronter trois listes la dernière à
s'être déclarés avec vos voisins avant
second soir peut être respirer
bonsoir meloni poker vous êtes la tête
de liste ou pas cette liste c'est votre
première candidature à une élection déjà
pourquoi vous êtes lancé en politique
alors j'ai aujourd'hui 50 ans je suis
salarié dans l'industrie sur saint
quentin en yvelines et j'ai pensé qu'il
était important avec les compétences de
management de projets l'habitude de
gérer des budgets de faire aussi des
négociations surtout à l'international
de mettre ses compétences au service de
la municipalité au service des vies
sinoise et davy sinois pour apporter un
visage neuf et un regard neuf sur la
ville et pourquoi tête de liste pourquoi
tête de liste plus effectivement parce
que une première sur une liste est tout
de suite tête de liste beaucoup de
personnes me font la remarque c'est très
ambitieux nous parlons de démocratie
participative
nous avons fait un vote nous étions deux
anneaux candidater pour être tête de
liste et j'ai été choisi
peut-être que mon dynamisme a fait la
différence alors pour vous ce sont les
premiers pas dans la vie politique ce
n'est pas le cas de tous vos colistiers
et notamment jean achille est deuxième
rien vous sur la liste élue depuis 25
ans sur la commune il est actuellement
conseiller municipal d'opposition
vous vous servez tout l'expérience tout
à fait bien sûr je ne me serais pas
engagé seul dans une histoire aussi
importantes pour la vie municipale
j'ai dans l'équipe jean h en numéro 2
mais aussi geneviève tellier et
christophe pajot qui sont des élus
depuis quelques années et leur exode en
l'exposant l'opposition actuellement
alors on parle plus de minorités que
d'opposition pour ce qu il arrive aussi
que nous soyons d'accord avec les
propositions faites en conseil municipal
donc opposition ça donne l'impression
qu'on est systématiquement poser non on
a nos propres idées notre programme avec
trois grands axes que nous défendons une
ville éco responsable une ville
citoyenne avec la démocratie
participative est aussi une ville
solidaire à la liste de ceux là on va
aller développer un petit peu plus tout
à l'air moi je voudrais qu'on parle de
la liste de manière générale comment
elle s'est construite c'est plutôt une
historians t de centre gauche mais vous
la voulez non partisane tout à fait
parce qu'aujourd'hui nous nous sommes
soutenus par aucun parti
donc nous rassemblons des personnes qui
ont différents qui viennent de
différents horizons et nous nous
rassemblons autour de nos trois axes
comme je les dis à une ville éco
responsable une ville citoyenne est une
ville solidaire et justement pourquoi
ces trois axes alors parce que nous nous
retrouvons autour de ses piliers qui
pour nous sont des valeurs importantes
aujourd'hui une ville éco responsable
pourquoi parce que l'écologie est une
vraie préoccupation je suis moi-même
membres du bureau d'une amap association
pour le maintien de l'agriculture
paysanne
très investie dans cette association et
je pense que il est important de
s'occuper de la planète
nous voyons nous l'avons encore vu ce
week-end avec la tempête que nous
n'avons pas d'habitude ou être février
ça c'est le premier point la partie
ville citoyenne parce que nous pensons
qu'il faut aller plus loin et utiliser
beaucoup mieux les conseils de quartier
pour faire un lien url
hector de communication entre les villes
chinoises et les vies si noah et la
municipalité
justement de ce côté là vous proposer de
mettre en place une assemblée vicinaux à
ce qui serait composé de 30 personnes
elle serait en complément des conseils
de quartier nouvelle serait lé
remplacerait alors en complément des
conseils de quartier pourquoi parce que
la ville va avoir dans un bref avenir à
gérer des sujets très importants je
pense à la ligne 18 notamment qui va
entraîner des évolutions dans la ville
et nous avons besoin de prendre le recul
est de prendre des décisions
stratégiques pour intégrer au mieux ces
évolutions dans notre vie donc l'éco
quartier qui se construit actuellement
rentrer dans cette thématique
l'éco-quartier et déjà décidé donc
difficile de dire qu'on va l'étudier
puisque les décisions sont déjà prises
mais toutes les nouvelles décisions à
prendre devront être prises avec
toujours je le répète à nouveau nos
trois piliers pour avoir une stratégie
globale et cohérente
alors on sait que l'un des enjeux
notamment des villes de
voisins-le-bretonneux c'est la
circulation aux heures de pointe de la
ville est engorgé où s'étaient notamment
claire des 91 devienne un boulevard
urbain mêlant logements commerces
services activités économiques des
explications supplémentaires de ce alors
effectivement la circulation est un
sujet récurrent dans la ville de voisins
puisque voisins se trouve aussi portes
du parc naturel régional de chevreuse
donc en tant que porte bas il ya
beaucoup de voitures qui passent par la
porte notamment 600 véhicules heure aux
heures de pointe dans voisin sud
les solutions
doivent être prises aussi avec
l'agglomération et aussi avec les villes
du parc naturel régional
imaginez qu'on ferme la ville serait
utopique donc il faut trouver des
solutions à nouveau et nous prônons la
démocratie participative et la
concertation avec les habitants pour
trouver des solutions et gino pérali
soir sur les aides apporteriez pour
réguler cette circulation nous dans
notre axe de solidarité nous pensons
aussi beaucoup aux transports collectifs
trouver des solutions notamment en
termes de transport collectif
interurbain pour délester les véhicules
qui arrivent de la vallée de chevreuse
et aussi à l'intérieur de la ville
réduire le trafic interne avec notamment
la mise en place d'un plan vélo et d'un
plan marche car souvent on ne se rend
pas compte que les distances sont
relativement courtes et qu'on va parfois
beaucoup plus vite à pied ou en vélo
qu'en voiture
vous souhaitez aussi transformé voisin
de villages villes villages en ville
urbaine
mais ce que cela sous-entend pas plus de
construction et donc peut-être plus de
circulation voisin bordeaux ne fait
partie de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
dans ce sens il est intégré aux
évolutions de l'agglomération il ne faut
pas oublier que notre ville a quand même
perdu presque mille habitants durant les
dix dernières années un des classes
scolaires ont fermé et il faut notamment
pour faire vivre les commerçants qui
vivent dans la ville
avoir une attractivité et attirer des
jeunes familles pour attirer des jeunes
familles nous pensons qu'il est
important d'avoir un plan ambitieux
notamment à travers des outils de
logements solidaires je pense à
l'exemple de ce qui a été fait dans la
ville de rennes où on sépare le foncier
du bâti pour réduire le prêt d'accession
à la propriété et ceci pour permettre
donc d'avoir d'attirer des familles des
jeunes familles aujourd'hui ça l'a été
dit pour montigny le bretonneux et c'est
le même sujet pour voisins le bretonneux
le prix du mètre carré est un frein à
l'installation des jeunes familles dans
notre vie et peut-être du côté des
logements sociaux aussi on sait que
voisin n'atteint pas les 25% avec la
musette à 18 5%
c'est dans votre programme de construire
des logements sociaux
alors effectivement les logements
sociaux nous avons une obligation légale
d'arriver à 25 % sinon il ya des
des contreparties financières qui sont
demandées donc il est clair que nos
étudiants ont aussi la possibilité de
faire un effort de ce côté là qui
s'intégrera dans un plan global
d'urbanisme qui sera d'ailleurs un sujet
qui sera traité lors du débat planifier
ce samedi 22 février
chez nous c'est notre plateau on arrive
à la fin de cet entretien mais là tu
respires as qu' il y à des réunions de
campagne
à noter pour ceux qui voudraient allez
vous rencontrer alors tout à fait nous
avons des réunions de campagne qui sont
indiqués sur notre site internet www 1
avant ce point fr où toutes les
informations les dates les horaires et
les lieux sont indiqués merci et
béatrice au pire à je le rappelle vous
êtes tête de liste de avec vos voisins
avance pour ces élections et sont
également candidats pour la commune deux
voisins le bretonneux la maire sortante
alexandra rosetti et le conseiller
d'opposition olivier afonso pour
terminer direction saint cyr l'école à
présent pour poursuivre notre tour
d'horizon des principaux enjeux des
municipales arrivée du tram 13 express
problèmes de stationnement et de
circulation encore aménagement des
nouveaux quartiers un renard ou fait le
point négatif de 2 min objectif pour
saint cyr l'école accueillir fin 2020 le
tram très express qui reliera la ville à
saint germain en laye en 30 minutes
les travaux préparatoires ont eu lieu en
le tram 13 entrera en correspondance
avec le rer c est avec les lignes n ai
eu à la gare de saint césaire pour
transporter 4 millions de voyageurs par
an
la tangentielle ouest permettra dans les
années à venir à désenclaver la ville et
à limiter les embouteillages depuis le
début des travaux pour le tram 13 la
ville peinent à se désengorger
embouteillages déviation et routes
barrées se sont installés dans les rues
de saint cyr autre enjeu revaloriser le
centre ville et le patrimoine de saint
cyr pour que la commune ne devienne pas
qu'une ville dortoir de plus la ville
manque de places de stationnement et de
trottoirs ce qui empêche les riverains
de rejoindre le centre facilement
incivilités tensions entre bandes
rivales
la sécurité est un des enjeux de la
campagne pas de caméra de sécurité
encore dans les quartiers sensibles
de plus certains candidats dénoncent un
manque d'agents de voirie et de police
de proximité
une ville qui a grandement évolué au fil
des années notamment avec la
construction du quartier charles renard
depuis maintenant 12 ans les travaux
sont en cours mais 500 logements sur les
25 hectares de terrains destinés à
accueillir de nouveaux saint cyrien un
enjeu majeur pour la ville qui doit
maintenant mettre en place des
structures pour accueillir les habitants
car la commune va voir sa population
passer de 15 à 20 mille habitants et
dans le cadre de cette campagne des
municipales tv 78 en association etc
radio sensations vous propose des débats
entre les candidats
ce lundi soir émission consacrée à
montigny le bretonneux c'est à retrouver
à chaque fois à 20h sur tv 78 sur la
feuille la fréquence 98 points 4 %
sations yvelines le replay sur tv
soixante dix huit points comme c'est la
fin de ce journal
merci de nous avoir suivis belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]